[Music]
assassin's creed is all about giving
players the thrill of leaping into
history and reliving pivotal moments of
our past
it has already been 15 years since out
of year and the first assassin's creed
game welcomed you to the brotherhood in
2007.
today marks the beginning of our
celebrations
for the months to come we've prepared
surprises unexpected collaborations
rewards community activities and more
we want to celebrate our 15th
anniversary with you and all the people
that shared their passion for our
franchise
whether you want to relive your first
assassin's creed memories get involved
in the celebrations or learn more about
the future of the brand we'll get you
covered in the months to
come exciting news about assassin's
creed starts now with an update on
what's to come in assassin's creed
valhalla
launching assassin's creed valhalla and
expanding upon its story and gameplay
throughout the first year has been an
incredible adventure
after two-story expansions that saw iowa
battle against a druidic cult in ireland
and then throw themselves into the siege
of paris and war-torn franchia we dove
into norse mythology with our ambitious
third expansion don of ragnarok with
assassin's creed crossover stories we
even brought back a surprise visitor
from the past who joined up with
eyeboard to fight a mysterious curse in
the isle of skye
i'm glad you invited me here tonight
on top of this narrative content since
launch we've added several free game
moves and activities to the world of
assassin's creed valhalla
now for the first time in the franchise
we're offering a second year free post
lunch content with our returning
festivals mastery challenge pack 2 an
armory update and new tombs to explore
this fall to close the mystery behind
tombs of the fallen
but that's not all this summer we're
offering a unique take on assassin's
creed gameplay it is my pleasure to
present the first look at our latest and
most ambitious game mode the forgotten
saga which will be free to all
assassin's creed valhalla players
[Music]
you do well to hide behind your monsters
daughter of loki
so
you're going back to nephilim
as many times as it takes
it is time to go to hell
each time you cast me out will only make
me stronger
we're excited for you to experience this
summer a new roguelite-inspired journey
into niflheim the spectacular realm of
the dead
and stay tuned until the end of the year
for one last surprise
we will reveal the last episode of iowa
story as a free chapter for all players
as well
in assassin's creed history has always
been our playground and discovery tour
is the ideal game mode to discover and
learn with content free of violence and
tailored for learning it is perfectly
suitable for all audiences including
schools
for the assassin's creed valhalla team
immersing players in the long gone world
of the vikings in the saxons has been a
driving passion
encouraged by feedback from teachers and
students we are proud to take a new step
in facilitating access to learning by
releasing today a standalone version of
discovery tour viking age for xbox and
playstation consoles as well as stadia
and luna streaming platforms
we're also honored to be partnering with
mcgill university in canada to develop
curriculum guides for teachers and
students available online for free to
help them make the most of discovery
tour ancient egypt ancient greece and
viking age as learning tools for the
classroom
we want to celebrate our 15th
anniversary with you by releasing a free
title update that our community has been
passionately asking for
60 frames per second support for
assassin's creed origins is now
available
experience ancient egypt under the reign
of cleopatra now in 60 fps on xbox and
playstation next gen concert
to celebrate with all of our players we
will be hosting a free weekend for
assassin's creed origins from june 16th
to june 20th
[Music]
the beautiful world of ancient egypt is
a great place to start revisiting and
celebrating past assassin's creed games
our 15th anniversary is about rewarding
you for your incredible support to get
started several sets of assassin's creed
origins tattoos along with the naval
pack will be available this week in
assassin's creed valhalla
right now head to our anniversary
website and learn more on how to get
involved with the celebrations
take part in our weekly challenges for a
chance to earn prizes and share your
favorite assassin's creed memories by
using hashtag ac15 as we leap into
history
join us this september as we unveil the
future of assassin's creed during a very
special event we can't wait to show you
what's in store
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
assassin's creed 15th anniversary
celebration event my name is yousef i'll
be one of your hosts today i'm joined by
my co-host chassis of ascencio jesse how
are you today
hey i'm excited that was very exciting
stuff so i'm happy to be here to
celebrate assassin's creed with all of
you and we have a special guest oh yes
we do uh we are joined by uh assassin's
creed producer jose ariza jose thank you
so much for joining us
oh it's my pleasure this is uh exciting
and thrilling all at once
uh yes we are very happy to be
showcasing all the news and
announcements that y'all just saw uh but
we're also gonna be hanging out with
y'all for
uh a little bit right now and showing
off the assassin's creed origins 60
frames per second boost um we're playing
it right now as you can see i am uh
rioting uh on the back of my camel on
the way to alexandria um jose this game
was already beautiful silky smooth the
60 frames per second boost just makes it
doubly more so it feels so good to play
yeah for sure i mean it's uh it's
interesting i just uh you know reloaded
it into my console i started playing it
again and it's it's amazing uh just
seeing it sort of refreshed and
i don't know there's a certain elegance
to it the desert the grandiosity of it
it's pretty awesome to see it in 60
frames and see how how beautiful it
looks yeah i agree and
like honestly i i haven't been back to
egypt you know in quite some time now
i think it's been about you know like
two years since i i've played origins
and it just it just feels so good to be
back um
i'm i started a new game plus here you
can see i'm already level 55.
awesome i had plenty of this game so now
you're jumping back into new gameplay
yes exactly as one does yeah but it
looks beautiful uh jose so let's
celebrate this game celebrate assassin's
creed um so yeah origins tell us about
your role on this game you were producer
god that feels like a lifetime ago so at
that point i believe i was associate
producer and i was in charge of
basically uh do being the liaison with
all other code of studios it was a
massive production
uh and it was my pleasure to be able to
work with all the studios that were
participating you know sofia
singapore bucharest
i feel like i'm forgetting somebody
sorry um but it's been you know it's
been quite a while and it was amazing
being part of this production it was
also officially my first full assassin's
creed production as i had just joined
the studio and it was
it was amazing uh sort of a
being part of this entire production
with so many awesome talented people
passionate people it was also a really
interesting time of the franchise
obviously re-envisioning what assassin's
creed would be for the future so it was
it was thrilling and nerve-wracking to
say the least
i imagine there was there must have been
uh you know a lot of uh excitement and
you know maybe
internal pressure that you were feeling
of you know bringing the
the game back the brand back
yeah absolutely i mean assassin's creed
is beloved by players around the world
right and there's a certain expectation
of
what the brand is what the brand you
know the tenants the pillars of the
brand it was really fascinating uh
trying to find out
how do we bring assassin's creed into an
open world how do we give
agency to the players of how they play
it how they consume and there are so
many changes
you know it's funny watching it right
now it feels like yeah yeah of course
this is exactly how it should have been
you know for the player perspective
maybe uh you know this feels like yes of
course why would it be anything other
than this but when you're on the other
side of you know pre-production
production
asking all those questions of you know
what is the dna of the brand what is
really assassin's creed
the areas where we could experiment or
not or or evolve the brand and certain
things that we absolutely wanted to keep
uh so yeah it was a it was fascinating
it was
preserving the dna while evolving at the
same time
uh i you know speaking that yeah as long
as you talk about dna uh my favorite
thing and the one thing
uh to me that i never get tired of in
assassin's creed is these sync points
and so
uh as long as as long as these are here
um i'm always going to be a a happy
camper um it's just one of my favorite
things i never get tired even after
doing them you know in
across every ac you know so many times
it's to me it nothing showcases what
the you know the verticality the the the
beauty of ac like those
yeah you know even that's a perfect
point right people uh assume that yeah
uh sing points are always there they're
you know they're a given they're you
know
hit the easy button and it's done but
even within the context of egypt right
like saying how do we want the camera to
move oh my god now we're in a massive
open world and you can see very far into
the background uh making sure that it
was a the right camera movement the
right speed
all these little things that players
don't see we had to like re-assess
under this you know open world scenario
yeah
by the way say that
sorry
i was gonna say well i was gonna say by
the way i noticed that my camera is
really bright this is obviously to be
it is in light
yeah yeah yeah it's like i'm in the
desert
he's coming to us live from alexandria
that's that's
wouldn't that be amazing
also yes we are live uh we can see the
chat so if you have any questions about
ac origins for jose drop them in the
chat and we'll ask them so yes we do see
you and yusuf is playing in real time
right now so that is happening we are
playing
ac origins in 60 fps on ps5 it's all
also available on xbox series xns
so you can jump into that and if you
missed that video earlier uh there's a
free weekend coming for ac origins june
16th to the 20th so if you haven't
played or want to jump back in
go for it on xbox and playstation next
gen consoles and play 60fps
but yeah we are live so if you have
questions please
let us know in the chat but jose i'll
start with a question for you um so i
saw an internal interview with you at
ubisoft and you said your best memory
was working working here was e3 2017 and
you said getting ac origins into
people's hands for the first time so can
you tell me more about that and what
that moment was like
yeah
uh
let me see if i can vocalize it right
you know the production had already been
going i think for three years at a time
and everybody was working really hard to
to re-envision to move the brand to
evolve the brand into this new open
world you know there's a lot of changes
that went into this uh
we went from a mission driven uh system
to a quest through a system that you
could consume however you want it
there were so many changes that went
into this and obviously uh
the people that work in the brand love
the brand to love assassin's creed
and is sort of doing this
meditation of everything we wanted to
bring into origins and obviously every
choice we made was because we really
truly felt every director every producer
everybody in the team that really felt
that was the right
choice the right thing to do
but nobody had seen it
so for me specifically uh being part of
that e3 doing the private demos
there was this moment of exhilaration
that you're happy to share what the team
has been working on and
especially for me you know i was
thrilled to be able to to be on the
floor to give the demos to represent the
team and
the directors and everybody and and you
know
it's a
huge honor to to be part of the brand
and to represent everybody's hard work
and talent
but on the other hand
it was nerve-racking
nobody had
nobody knew what it was yeah yeah and
you give
the controller to to a player a lot of
them are our media a lot of them are
streamers youtuber
some celebrities even you know we're in
l.a
at e3
and there's this moment that
you're super proud you're super excited
you want to show it but also a part of
you saying oh my god please please like
it and we hope
that you see what we see we hope that uh
that this really uh our vision
translates and it's able to be
understood
and those very first demos that i gave
it was phenomenal you know that that
that fear but also you know you're
looking you give the controller to
somebody and you're looking at them and
you're like yeah
yeah you know
so are you like just directly looking
are you kind of looking away or just
like nervous about that that sounds very
nervous
in some cases uh some people say no no
you drive i want you to see you play it
yeah you also get some of them some of
the media people that are so stoic
and you're playing you're explaining and
then you know their total poker face
just like
a monster and you don't know like uh
are you loving it are you hating it uh
you know
and at the same time as we progress
giving more demos
uh
i think there was one person that
actually said
you've given me the assassin's creed
that i never knew i wanted and it's
phenomenal
uh
yeah you can probably see me getting a
little emotional because it was so
amazing just being there and and seeing
people say
this is exactly
i didn't know i wanted this but this is
exactly what it should be uh you know
giving the demos also you noticed uh all
the npcs you know we had the smart uh
you know the meta ai network
having the same demo
or having people play the exact portion
of the game but seeing different results
seeing different enemies uh you know the
wildlife
at some point i saw i think it was a an
alligator and a hippo get into a fight
and the guy is like oh was that supposed
to happen and i said no honestly i've
never seen that i don't know
what you know what events happened for
those two animals to be in that location
and fight but it was super
it was nerve-racking and it was amazing
and it was such a
communal sigh of relief and saying
yes we
we did deliver uh yes people agree with
our vision
you know we still held
the pillars of the brand the dna
and yeah it was a
i think cathartic it was a very
cathartic moment for me you know and now
you know and it was also my uh my first
assassin's creed production right so
for me there was also that element of
i'm joining
sort of uh at this time of change of
this nexus of change
and you know you're you're thinking
god please i hope i hope it goes well i
i hope that that's an exciting time to
join though yeah that sounds like an
ideal time exciting and also
yeah and also terrifying right yeah you
know we always do our best work hoping
that everybody would love it hoping that
everybody will be entertained
uh you know it's sort of uh that uh
that's saying that nobody has an ugly
baby right so it's that moment where you
show
people the baby and you're like i hope
people like the baby you know
speaking of yeah i i
love this scene so much uh it's our
first introduction to aya here
um i is great and like like i think to
me like it was just so cool seeing
a husband and wife that were like
in love and hat you know like obviously
you know they are on a quest to avenge
the death of their you know son but um
it was like it was a healthy
relationship and i feel like that's
something that's so rare to see in games
yeah you know and it's amazing also that
you get to see the trajectory of from
the past to the present
to the future when you meet them again
in the hidden ones
uh
and we know we were so uh attuned to
their relationship that we felt you know
in the hidden ones we needed to
acknowledge right they have that moment
where we're sort of uh them saying you
know what it's okay we did well yeah but
seeing that trajectory and it's funny
because it wasn't a big
speech it wasn't melodramatic
it was just a moment where you i killed
it i feel and i hope that we captured
that the journey as a couple as people
as human beings that they had and in the
end just saying you know what we don't
need to give a big speech
we're okay we're cool yeah
yeah that's actually it's it's
i'm so happy you bring that up that is
one of my favorite moments in gaming
period it's just after bike and i have
been you know
separated at the end of uh you know the
the game and um them coming back
together and and reuniting there for
that moment
there's a shot where they you know they
their foreheads touch and like they
embrace and like it just it fills my
heart every time
it's super nice to hear you say that you
know
i know the narrative team worked really
hard to give
value to that moment without being uh
giving over exposition of what the
player should or should not be feeling
or what bike and
ayah should be feeling so
it was that subtlety i think was
represented throughout the game right
carrying the spectrum of emotions
of you know my ex quest his motivations
is motivation
the rift between them
all these little things that
you know we want the player to be
emotionally connected
yeah i think i think it was a it was a
she wants this complete success at least
you know for for me that that's trust me
that's my opinion on it
agreed very strong story and just their
relationship is just something you don't
forget from this series
it's
be careful
don't point that at your fingers
there
i will go to the palace and discover who
uses the seal of the snake
uh it's funny
too jose yeah you were saying earlier um
you were talking about
showing this game to people for the
first time and then them you know saying
oh this isn't
you know i didn't
realize this is what i wanted but it's
exactly what i wanted um i i have a
slightly similar but slightly different
um
uh impression of when origins was first
announced and when we first got to play
it um it was also you know at the very
beginning of my ubisoft journey here um
but the way i i'm i don't think i've
actually told you i'm actually i happen
to be egyptian um
and so origins
it was is always the game i wanted but
never actually thought i would ever get
um and then you know you were not the
only one
yeah that was a top top request by the
by the fans yeah yeah but you know i
think i think even more so you know as
you you're talking about the
the the new um
you know uh quest system and and how
much um how much was put into actually i
don't think i'm going right away uh how
much was put into
the culture the time period the setting
um to me it felt like a game that so so
wholeheartedly embraced egypt and its
people um you know not only of of of the
time but
you know the the location itself um and
it it
it was everything i could have hoped for
and more and you know i would say
because of that it's it's the most
important assassin's creed to me
that's amazing to hear you know and and
back when we were doing the press tour
for origins uh one of the proudest
speaking points for me was all the
research that went into this uh old you
know working with egyptologists uh
trying to absorb
and and
we're not just
assassin's creed as a brand it's not
just about being in a setting and a
place but understanding right uh
honoring
the the magnitude of what used to be the
you know the egyptian empire at that
point uh
understanding the context you know
understanding uh the significance of
cleopatra right that was uh everybody
knows cleopatra but i don't think
everybody appreciates the all the nuance
to her rising to power uh
you know
the fact that uh
the pyramids were already ancient by the
time she arrived all these layer upon
layer upon layer and you know we really
uh i was obviously one of the masses
that had never really dug too deep so we
know pop culture references of egypt we
know the pyramids exist we know the
sphinx we know cleopatra you know
we know all these things because they're
sort of in the eat they're out there
right but digging into this and really
uh at least for me educating myself
and seeing this represented in 3d on the
screen
with elegance with respect
and really uh honoring you know like how
magnificent it really was uh so it's
amazing to hear you say that and i think
that's a that's one of the awesome
things about assassin's creed in general
like
being able to reflect and reflect and
honor some of these older cultures
absolutely and you know
i i know i'm not alone in this um when i
say that uh i've i have learned a ton
about history through assassin's creed
going all the way back to the very first
game um and i'm sure you know every time
we play these games we have people
coming out in chat telling us you know
that they've they've learned as much
from ac as they have from from a
textbook um
uh and i know you know that uh discovery
tour is something that
was implemented for the first time with
origins um
i was wondering if you could you know
speak a little bit about that and you
know obviously viking age now is coming
standalone to consoles as well um you
know what has that whole week experience
been like
i would love to answer your question but
i have a question for you first oh hit
me was there anything was there anything
that you didn't know you know coming
from egypt that you didn't know that you
learned while playing origins that you
were like oh
that's a that's surprising you know
that's a really that's a really good
question um so i i actually thought i
knew quite a bit because i um i i
studied um
classical architecture uh that was what
my you know degree was in so i studied
uh greek roman and to a little lesser
extent egypt so i wasn't super super
familiar with
um egyptian um
architecture in that way but one of one
of the things that that i love that i
never really realized because even when
i you know you do study egyptian
architecture it's usually not of this
time period it's usually you know the
the pyramids and um
you know the old kingdom and so one of
the things that i think origins does
such a good job of that i never that i
never really realized is that at the
time of cleopatra you know cleopatra is
essentially as much greek as she is
egyptian and you know this is a time
when the romans are coming to egypt when
when they're you know alexandria is a
greek city um
and
the thing that this game
showed to me and taught me was that you
know at this time during ptolemaic egypt
egyptians themselves were kind of
second-class citizens in their own in
their own homeland um so that that was
something i learned um just just by
playing the game not even not even
getting into discovery tour and all the
things you learn in discovery tour
that's my answer for you
you know it's interesting like obviously
seeing alexandria be reconstructed
because you know it had to be
reconstructed from all the information
data plans that we had you know how much
of it
doesn't exist right right it's it's you
know
but anyways to answer your question
about discovery tour uh it was all this
research right we had to do an amazing
amount of research we collaborated with
museums around the world trying to get
uh artifacts scans information we
obviously knew that we wanted to be as
genuine as possible and get as much
information as we could to be educated
right and to
really uh pay
to the culture
during all the research working with you
know egyptologists and really absorbing
this we realized
there's so much uh mystery magic so much
information that that hasn't been you
know collected in a way that could be
digested and obviously we wanted to
share this information right it's like
we wrote a thesis on egyptology but how
do you share that without
without saying ah wait stop the gameplay
uh stop fighting that dude and listen to
this story that we have to tell you
right and you know that was uh basically
how discovery tour was uh was born
saying you know we've learned so much
and there's so much here that is so
exciting and mysterious and amazing how
do we share that how do we share that
and obviously
going through uh the thought process of
well we want us to be accessible not
just for players but also for children
and schools
okay you know we need to remove the
combat we need to make it a as
accessible as possible we need to uh
highlight we can't share everything but
how do we highlight and you know you've
seen even with the discovery toward the
evolution
you know
from origins to now the viking age
we're still trying to find ways to to
entertain while being educational and i
know educational is not a loved word by
everybody but
but there's a lot of really cool stuff
that you read it and you know like the
the factoid about the pyramids were
already there when cleopatra ascended to
the throne and they were already ancient
you know people when i share that with
people a lot of people would say what oh
you know i thought they were built for
her or you know all this like uh
information that is not correct that is
out there in the ether
correcting it and really uh
helping people to contextualize that
you know this is an ancient civilization
that rose to amazing heights for that
period and you know and even the
occupation right of the romans
how long they coexisted together
you know cleopatra ascending to the
throne as a woman in a
you know after the failure of
her you know the other pharaohs uh you
know all this was super intriguing and
it was a phenomenal to learn about and
also to share with people through the
discovery tour yeah and that's that's
another thing i think this game does a
great job too is showing how all these
cultures uh combined and how how their
gods combined even in their religious
beliefs and cultural beliefs all come
together and that how how prevalent that
was throughout history
but i do i love that cleopatra fact that
cleopatra and bayek you know lives
closer to today than they did to the
building of the pyramids um that's wild
i i i was here for for like a real
specific reason and this is like
honestly this is when i realized how
much
uh research and time and effort was put
into this game is when i saw these these
stones here in the middle of the street
and i remember tweeting this out at the
time and like
you know it was it was the closest i had
ever gone to going viral
at the time um when i saw these because
i was i was shocked like these these are
crosswalks y'all like these are ancient
crosswalks and the reason they're there
are these elevated stones
in the middle of the street um is
because oftentimes in ancient cities you
would just have
sewage basically running through the
streets or rainwater or whatever you
know what what have you um but you would
need elevated places for people to cross
and the reason it's not just like a
straight slab of um you know of raised
portion is that you still need carriages
and carts to be able to pass through so
you have these you know horse-drawn
carriages pass through and their wheels
are meant to go in between
all these stone tabs but pedestrians are
meant to cross on top of them so they're
not getting their feet dirty and things
like that from everything that's running
in the streets
and when i saw that i was like oh my god
they this is something that like
you know point zero one percent of
players would ever even notice ever even
think about ever know existed but
and and no one would miss if it was
wasn't there but
the debt you know the development team
put in that extra time and effort
because they wanted to make it as
realistic as possible
uh
you know trust me the level of research
uh that was put into oranges was
impressive you know it's it's
flora fauna uh even at one point we even
had the discussion of uh anything that
we built any location what is the
percentage of wood that you could use
because guess what there's not a lot of
wood in egypt right even the materials
like what type of rock
you know
all of this had to be
true to the culture to what was
available to them
uh
it's strange to be talking about
building a location a a military fort
and say no no wait wait you cannot use
more than x amount of wood because wood
was precious at that point you know and
players probably don't
you know
necessarily focus on that because
they're obviously they're busy playing
but all these little things that we have
to say well no it has to feel as
authentic as possible right the even the
swords the stones on the floor the
patterns all these things that could
just be uh taken as uh artistic choices
they're actually very informed and based
on
all the research that was done
yeah i mean i
i think it's one of those things that
you know even if you're not
you're maybe aware of them it it comes
through in the end
let's not die
all right i want to address the chat and
say hi to them because uh they've been
asking some questions the chat's been
flying by so i've grabbed as many as i
could uh and so thank you for sending
your love thank you for sending your
questions in i just want to shout out
some people who are sharing some love
dr xy i said i love this game series so
much thank you for your incredible
experience uh dubster said thank you
ubisoft for doing this event and these
kind of games i love it
um nick nakamata said i'm glad i can
finally play in 60 fps time to revisit
origins
uh and
anigmar said just wanted to tell you how
amazing ac origins was thanks to the
work of all the team and how it raised
the accessibility of the franchise i was
able to play ac games again it changed
my life in many ways love hearing that
stuff so thank you for sharing your
stories uh that's all amazing stuff so
uh let's go to some questions so taran
walker earlier asked what were the
biggest challenges in bringing
assassin's creed to an open world for
the first time
all of them
all of them i mean yeah i mean there was
so much i mean obviously the
going into an open world how you play
that open world right because we should
be able to go wherever you want to go
whenever you want to go trying to find
this formula going from a mission-driven
system to a quest system
changing the combat that was huge right
because now you're in an open world
where you can be surrounded by animals
or npcs and enemies uh changing the
combat from our old system to a hitbox
system which was uh you know it means
that if you have a long axe and you spin
around
and
the enemies are near you you should be
able to hit every single one of them you
know it's no longer the the queue system
of uh i'm only fighting the guy that's
in front of me take your ticket you know
now serving enemy 355 step up you know
it's sort of all these uh
rationalization of how to
how do we give players a choice to
basically do anything they wanted go
anywhere they wanted
there was also the the big question of
the desert right
uh
you know to be honest the first time i
heard oh we're doing assassin's creed in
egypt in the desert i thought of the
pyramids but i also thought
oh it's a that's a lot of desert right
like uh
how do we address that how do we direct
the player to pockets of content how do
we still
make it interesting entertaining uh
you know the sandstorm that was a huge
challenge
you know
because it has to look good right it has
to look good and you have to be able to
to appreciate it feel like it's there it
needs to be substantial
constructing the pyramids that was also
uh
i think that we absolutely could not get
wrong you know and it's not just the
visual of the pyramids but also climbing
the pyramids sliding down the pyramids
um an interesting anecdote even even
i'm sure you guys probably remember
there was a slight uh
interesting factoid after the game ship
when we sort of predicted uh
i forget which one of the variants it
was i think i think it was a great
pyramid where we sort of speculated what
there should have been a chamber
and yes i remember this
yeah and then a month later
egyptologists discovered that there was
a chamber where we predicted because we
did all the all the you know all the
research and and we knew we had to get
it right right we knew uh you know
people like you music you know who are
egyptian or egyptian descent we had to
get it right we couldn't just you know
make up whatever we wanted so it was
amazing that our research led to us
saying you know we really feel that
there should be a chamber here because
structurally the way is built so we we
sort of theorized and then i think it
was a month or two months after the game
was released
you know
it was discovered and it was verified
that indeed there was a chamber there i
think
at one point players were accusing us of
being templars
because we had this information which
you know it's the best component i guess
that we could get uh but yeah there was
a lot of it that was a challenge and not
just honoring the brand but also
honoring the egyptian culture at that
point it's uh
it was a little stressful let's see
a little stressful yes
yeah just a little bit
yeah rafferty rules twitch said wow
that's so cool top tier research and uh
spliff says thank you so much for
origins have hundreds of happy hours
with this wonderful game oh glad to hear
it thank you guys that's awesome uh and
to let everyone know too um we're going
to be playing for a little bit longer
here uh but
our what our
our uh showcase here of the ac origins
is not gonna be the end of the stream um
after this
we have news coming from um ac stories
so um the kind of the assassin's creed
uh extended uh storytelling including
comics graphic novels manga
so stay tuned there will be a lot more
information too about uh further ac
stories
that's right and there's plenty more to
come in the coming months so please just
stay tuned we're celebrating ac for a
long time and then as mentioned if you
missed the video earlier uh there's a
special event in september to learn more
and if you want to learn more about what
you missed earlier in the stream head to
assassinscreed15.com
and you'll get all your information
there but we can kind of go over some of
the big highlights from what was
mentioned in the first six minutes jose
um and you were in that video so
we've got uh
yes
no it was great so year two content for
acv uh free to all players that's very
exciting tell us a little bit more about
that uh from what you mentioned in the
video
oh my god so uh yeah uh second year of
uh
you know ac valhalla free content uh
obviously we're doing the the second
part with what we just did the second
part to mastery challenge that's too
slowly fallen and i guess there's that
little surprise uh the forgotten saga
which is uh
let me let me let me think of my pr
training to not give any spoilers
we obviously announced that it's
inspired you know very roguelite
inspired we wanted to sort of uh explore
for those of you that are fans that have
been with us in valhalla since the
beginning you probably have heard me say
in the past that we wanted to explore
right we wanted to experiment we invited
players to come with us and this is sort
of the culmination of that exploration
of saying you know
it's such a rich brand and taking the
historical taking the mythological
uh
you know for those ancient cultures it's
literally impossible to separate the two
right people literally uh woke up and
went to bed acknowledging deities and
and all the values that they had
i think the forgotten saga is it's the
culmination of that or was saying you
know let's let's explore this try
something else let's step outside of our
comfort zone
let's find a way to tell the story uh
obviously for the people that are
familiar with the mythology they
they probably know the myth the balder
for the players that laid down the rock
and rock to sort of know
what triggered ragnarok
having this moment to tell the story of
as a father what would odin do right
just rescue your son to get him back to
not have him live in this honorable
death
and basically
coming up with the gameplay around this
moment and say you know what uh
we're gonna go in a different direction
it's still assassin's creed valhalla
it's still you know
if you play the main game you're going
to play this and say yes i get the
controls i understand everything but
also sort of uh
turning some of the formula upside down
much like a rogue light obviously you're
intended to die
the more that you play and die the more
powerful you get
as you sort of get kicked out of
navalheim the story
unwraps and then you should really
understand what's what's happening and
you really uh
there's some subtlety to the
storytelling as to why odin is trying
and why what it means to him you know
he's not there
as odin
the old father he's the he's heirs odin
the father you know he's not welcome
there he's depowered
uh he sort of needs to build his power
up to be able to rescue baldur uh i
think that's all i can say without
giving any spoilers for sure for sure
you know what
the best part the best part is that it's
an exploration is the team sort of uh
saying you know what let's let's try
something else let's do something else
let's give something unique to the
players
and it's free
everybody can download it
yeah exactly you know
you know and to be honest it's been
amazing having the community
be part of this journey with us and
we'll be listening to the feedback you
know exploring trying new things growing
from the feedback uh
the forgotten saga is sort of the
culmination of a lot of ideologies that
we merged uh a lot of it you know new
things that we wanted to try
i hope the players play it and like it
you know it's another e3 moment right
where we say okay we're going a
different direction to be experimental
we hope we think this is really cool and
we hope players also think it's cool
i want to point out a comment that rad
dude said in the chat where uh said jose
is great you can really tell his passion
for the ac brand
uh and yeah i totally agree
yeah
absolutely
uh let's see if there are any other
questions so i got one from y obz who
said uh what's your favorite aspect
about bayek
that's a tough question i think
well you know man there's so many uh i
don't want to you know minimize him
i think to me the the
who he is the fact that that you know is
a major he he he feels
the duty
but it's not just a duty it's not just a
job right he really wants to preserve
the ancient
culture of egypt right and it's a time
of turmoil and i think
i think as human beings we all have that
right we want to to stay true to our
morals we want to you know uh
make sure that that who we are what we
believe in is reflected in what we do
uh you know we were talking before the
stream about you know how kids love
bayek because he is this figure of
of
an upstanding citizen that is there to
protect the people that is there to to
to preserve their quality of life you
know you could say that he's a sheriff
but he's really not just a sheriff
because he honestly really truly wants
to do good for the people right he
really truly embodies this role heart
and soul
and i think seeing his journey
you know it's
inspiring in some ways because i think
as human beings we all have that of you
know we want to do good we want to do
good by not just ourselves but the
people around us and he sort of embodies
this and how far he will go
in his journey for this
and he'll go pretty far yeah
that's a really good answer though uh
yeah and like i i i feel that really
hard because i
um you know one of the things that
origins allowed you to do which i'm a
big fan of obviously is uh you know
customized bikes hair right you could
have long hair no beard beard long hair
you know i i tend to go for the uh short
hair on top of the beard you know who
would have thought oh wait i wonder why
yeah yeah
but the other thing i really like is
that you can you can choose whether or
not to keep bikes hood up or not like
yeah up or down and to me i never put
the hood up and that's just me you could
there's no wrong way to do it obviously
you can you can absolutely play with the
hood if you like
but to me it was because of everything
you just said that bike is is a magi he
is a protector of the people of egypt he
is not you know um
at this time in the story he is not
someone who who is hiding and you know
working in the shadows he is a protector
of the people of egypt and he has
nothing to be ashamed of for that and or
nothing to uh to hide hide from in that
aspect um and it it's important to him
that you know he is he is there for the
people of egypt and that he is he's
visible to them uh so i always kept kept
hood down because of that
you know as i'm speaking i'm realizing
that maybe there is a metaphor in there
somewhere about who bike is and sort of
uh
you know his evolution of
wanting to to stay true to the old but
also embracing the new moving forward
and finding out how he best can be there
for the people
maybe this is a metaphor also of origins
itself right trying to preserve the dna
of the brand and also uh doing right by
the players and saying well
it's time to evolve
and we're going to take the good all the
traditions of what our ac and push them
forward i don't know if the writers
intended that but it feels like there's
a metaphor in there
i think i think yeah they would uh i'm
sure they would tend to agree i just
want to mention again that assassin's
creed origins is available on 60 fps on
xbox and ps next gen consoles uh and
there's a free weekend there we go free
weekend june 16th to the 20th so you
should jump back in or play for the
first time if you've never played before
it's the perfect time and so for
everything you missed earlier we had
some announcements at the beginning of
the stream uh head to
assassinscreed15.com to learn more
so we have our first true assassination
here
yeah we infiltrated this bath house
we're trying to assassinate
nothing but our hidden blade this is
bike's first assassination out here with
the hidden blade look up at that expanse
it's wild seeing this again
giving me a total flashbacks
this to me is what assassin's creed is
all about you know like there's there's
your target they are the entrance is
guarded you're not just walking right in
how do you how do you get about this
stop
simonides
there's a link in the chat now for the
free weekend if you want more
information
you said do you have any uh hot gas on
uh ptolemy how about some ptolemy
specifically
[Music]
no gosh nothing that comes to mind um
can i do anything sorry i'm a little bit
uh preoccupied here with yeah
uh and the free weekend uh so someone
was asking if it was pc only no it's uh
also an xbox um playstation and stadia
in addition to pc
shout out to the back hair
representation too in this game you know
oh mystery solve remember uh the
you know those moments that we wanted to
uh to explain to players why why the
salute you know and
him losing his finger and how that
became iconic for the brand
yeah that was that was i i remember
gasping the first time i saw that of
being like that's why you know and it
was it was really out of desperation
more so than anything
else oh
i had nothing to do with that disaster
it's too late for your lies
anubis
awaits
i think these conversations to post
assassination obviously it's something
ac has always done
um
but but to me they're some of my
favorite parts in every game where you
never die you know you get to speak to
these people on their deathbed
essentially and
you know
what they reveal at that moment what
they what what ideologies they hold they
grasp onto still
some of them are quite
poetic you know there's quite a lot of
gravitas to those moments
well and even you go back all the way to
the first the ac you know all that year
puts a feather over you know his
victims and it was you know it was never
really explained but then we get that
that explanation
um
here in in origins where it's you know
it's a hair on feather and it's uh you
know
it's it's it's meant to be for the
afterlife
this part of the streams fairly soon but
we have more to show you uh we have a
video about assassin's creed stories so
if you're interested in the books the
manga more things about assassin's creed
stories uh that's to come right after
this
section where we're playing through
assassin's creed origins which we'll be
wrapping up shortly but yeah if you are
interested in
stories in different
mediums
we've got more for you coming up shortly
should we take a couple more questions
before we say goodbye
yeah sure or actually before i say
goodbye
oh yes well
well we're saying goodbye to you we're
going to show the video from assassin's
creed stories and then uh people will
see us again tomorrow we'll be back
tomorrow
but thank you so much for joining us
jose uh let's see if we have any other
questions in the chat
um
so eda boy said what made you choose
ancient egypt to set the origin story in
when
uh what made oh my god
oh
well it was a it was one of the top
requests by the fans and also going
far back enough in the timeline i think
it was uh 49 bc i think when the game
starts going far enough in the timeline
obviously we needed to visit a place in
time
before the original trilogy to explain
what was the
the seeds that were planted to create
the modern day brotherhood right so even
going back to the order of the ancients
going back you know we wanted to pick a
place in time that was far back enough
that that
allowed us to explain these little
things that became i guess you could say
pop culture within the instagram
and also the this
time and place uh you know i mentioned
earlier cleopatra there were so many
there were so many things about that era
and the social political circumstances
that it felt like you know what this is
uh
historically speaking it was such an
oddity for so many reasons that it felt
like you know what
this was a nexus
of two cultures coming together
trying to co-exist for a very long time
different religions different ideologies
uh different political structures
all this sort of gave us a really
fertile ground to say you know what this
feels like a
a time where you would have seen an
evolution of something right
it was a sort of like a pressure cooker
in a way
and yeah
so it felt like the the perfect setting
to tell an ancient story about how the
brotherhood was created
plus i mean it's one of the greatest
ancient civilizations so
maybe it was a little bit of a duh
moment
[Laughter]
it all makes sense
all right we're gonna bring this part of
the stream to a close and continue on
with ac stories uh but before we go just
wanna reiterate what we went over at the
very beginning of the stream if you
missed it uh year two content for
assassin's creed valhalla is coming free
to all players there's a new game mode
called the forgotten saga so be sure to
check that out it's a roguelite inspired
journey into niflheim uh and also
as you can see here assassin's creed
origin 60 fps on xbox and ps next gen
consoles free weekend coming june 16th
to the 20th so check that out uh for
everything that you uh missed go to
assassinscreed15.com
and there's a special event in september
to learn more about the future of
assassin's creed so stay tuned for that
we'll be celebrating assassin's creed
all the way until then
and even after that as well uh jose any
final words to the chat uh and to the
audience who love assassin's creed so
much
oof well i mean there's so much to play
i would say definitely uh try origins in
60 frames per second especially since
you have the free weekend uh it's you
know it's awesome seeing it and i know i
sound super biased but it looks
beautiful it's awesome seeing it in 60
frames
and also for those of you that are with
us in valhalla do check out the
forgotten saga when it comes out you
know it's a
wild imagining of a myth that i think
everybody knows
and also free so try it enjoy it the
best we can hope is for you guys to like
it or at least be entertained
well thank you for all that you do uh
yusuf so we're gonna go over to
assassin's creed stories next yeah jose
thank you so much y'all thank you so
much for rocking with us thank you oh
yeah jose you are welcome back anytime
you were
amazing thank you
uh but yeah we are going to kick it now
over to the assassin's creed stories uh
tons of information there be sure to
stick around for the the whole thing um
and we will see you all tomorrow right
here uh on this channel as well chassis
and i will be back playing some other
games but uh take care everyone and
happy 15th anniversary to assassin's
creed
indeed happy anniversary thank you guys
have a good one thanks a lot
[Music]
hello everyone my name is sebastian
bratis and i'm a community developer on
assassin's creed i want to start off by
welcoming you all to the assassin's
creed stories live stream this is the
second edition to the series so if you
happen to miss last year's stream
there'll be a link in the description to
that video
assassin's creed stories is a
celebration of all the amazing
transmedia projects coming from the
world of assassin's creed these projects
ranging from comic books novels manga
and podcasts showcase the love we all
have to this franchise and explore both
brand new stories and some unexpected
editions from the beloved heroes of the
brotherhood
we have a lot of exciting content to
talk about and we'll first start by
diving into the world of assassin's
creed valhalla i'll be speaking with
writers that crafted both the narrative
for the dawn of ragnarok expansion as
well as the companion comic book
published by dark horse then i'll have a
chance to discuss a historical podcast
series assassin's creed echoes of
history
with the co-writer and producer of that
project
finally we'll be shifting gears to focus
on some original upcoming
projects including a webtoon sequel to
assassin's creed black flag and a
discussion about the magus conspiracy
novel trilogy we have a lot of exclusive
content lined up so let's jump into it
now with assassin's creed forgotten
myths
assassin's creed valhalla forgotten
myths is a comic mini-series published
by darkhorse comics that serves as a
prequel to assassin's creed valhalla
dawn of ragnarok two of the three issues
are already out now in the u.s and in
canada with additional translations
coming soon today we're joined by some
special guests to talk more about the
mini series please welcome alex freed
and alice harakis hey
great to be here
all right perfect uh wonderful to have
both of you uh first i'd like to start
by learning a little bit more about uh
who both of you are and what you guys do
okay um my name's alex arakis i'm the
lead writer at ubisoft sophia
and i was responsible for the narrative
direction and the overall script writing
of assassin street valhalla
dawn of ragnarok
and i'm alexander freed i'm a novelist a
video game writer and relevantly today a
comic book writer and i wrote the script
for the forgotten myths comic it's a
pretty lengthy uh amount of writing
could could you give us a brief overview
about what forgotten this is about alex
f sure so forgotten myths is essentially
the the story of baldur and loki and
balder is the the son of odin the the
son of javi
the most beloved of the gods the best of
the gods god of light a courageous
warrior invulnerable to harm
he is seeking a
a new challenge in his godly life and he
decides he's going to make peace between
the fire giants of muspelheim and the
dwarves of swartholfem
and in order to do that he recruits the
help of loki who is of course not
particularly beloved by the gods
particularly by uh um
balder's father
so the the comics are basically the
story of their their adventures together
their weary relationship and
of course because it's based on
loosely north norse mythology uh it all
ends in fire and bloodshed and general
horribleness those stories often seem to
to skew towards the uh towards the the
horribleness
um so i guess obviously because there's
so much interconnectivity with with
norse mythology where does the idea for
this story originate as it relates to
assassin's creed valhalla okay i mean
the first question i think is why
mythological because assassin's creed
valhalla is a very
thorough game um
and they did such a great job covering
the historical side of
the north culture
so for us it was really about taking
something that obviously in
valhalla there is a mythological aspect
but it's not the main focus of the game
so for us it was an opportunity to
actually
jump in there and
um weave our own story and fill some of
the gaps that were understandably there
and really created a great playground if
you like
in terms of the actual um
why this story
norse mythology is so broad and you've
got this great
creation mythos you've got so many
beloveds of well-known stories about the
uh the gods and their various antics
going on
but we really needed something that
would allow us to connect
with the base game
um
and
the focus of the base game when it did
look at the mythological side of north
sculpture was to do with with ragnarok
and they what they did they they started
they showed how javi or odin
began his journey on this road that will
eventually lead him to ragnarok and his
um
his ultimate fate
and then they fast forwarded to how it
all ends
for russia was about coming in and
looking a bit more with a bit more
detail about that journey there it's
kind of like when you uh i do this all
the time when i start reading a book or
watching a movie i'll often
read the final chapter see how it ends
and then i'll go back it's about finding
out how you got there
most people i think know how ragnarok
ends especially those who played this
game so that's not a huge mystery the uh
the intrigue what was really interesting
was how does this character of javi um
of odin actually end up um with that
fate how does he embrace his fate if you
like
so that was really the
the um what
what really appealed to us in in this in
this story and that's where you saw what
um
uh took our focus if you like
i think that's really interesting
especially there's that sense of
inevitability or as you mentioned that
the conclusion is no but the
intrigue comes into the the meandering
ways in which we get there so
obviously knowing
yeah obviously knowing that in terms of
of north mythology and being able to
create stories from
mythology mythologies rich universes
rich characters were you both familiar
with norse tales before writing for the
game and for the comic or was this kind
of uncharted territory for you both
for me i had um
some uh
some knowledge
as a writer of 20 years it's one of
those things that
someone's always coming and asking you
let's do a vikings project and so you
always run off and do your research and
then you come back and they've changed
their mind they don't do about this
project but it does mean that you do get
quite a good knowledge over the years of
norse mythology and vikings etc
so
when
once we decided to do
this mythological story
i didn't have sort of like um the
absolute knowledge by any means but i
did have a good grounding
and then it was really very much a case
of me and the rest of the creative team
and the universe the writers just going
away and really immersing ourselves for
a month or two
in norse mythology
reading watching things which is
one of the best things about this job
you know you you get paid to do the
things you like doing like researching
these these fantastic cultures uh so
yeah uh it was a lot of around the clock
um uh getting into the soul like the
culture of the the north alexander do
you do
anything that on there yeah i mean it's
it's interesting to hear that story mine
was a little different so i i've been
fairly well steeped in uh norse
mythology since since i was a child but
had never really touched on anything
vaguely related to that that world in a
professional capacity until uh until
this comic came along and for me it was
very much
oh suddenly suddenly i'm playing with
these these toys that have
you know
well over a thousand years of history
they have all of this sort of
emotional power and historical strength
and
archetypal weight attached to them
and it was it was just tremendously
exciting to be working with that
um you know to to write something in in
a script like thor throws his hammer or
you know loki's shape changes into a
fish
and it it almost made it difficult to
remember
wait this needs to work as a story on
its own terms as well i can't just lean
entirely on the fact that
you know these have
these icons have built up this power
over
so many centuries and that they still
need to work as characters they still
need to have
recognizable emotions and go through
something that
works even divorced from the the
mythological background yeah it must be
a certain element of having to find a
way to deconstruct all the things that
you know that people know about these
characters like how do you how do you uh
compartmentalize all of that
it's really interesting how the kind of
the blurred lines between the comic the
cover the experience and production that
obvi obviously the game assassin's creed
is known for its obviously its beloved
narrative elements the experiences it
offers through its games and through
various transmedia projects in your
opinion how do comics offer a different
storytelling opportunity and
do you see comic books as being a
natural extension for the franchise or a
natural extension to gaming
i mean i've always felt like um an
author should be playing to the
strengths of the medium that they're
working in telling stories that really
only that medium can do and
games have so much to offer in that
regard um obviously interactivity is is
a beast that that no other medium can
even really touch upon it's it's so
powerful it is utterly unique
um and any game that leans into that
really just is is doing well by its its
own nature um a comic is never going to
be able to outdo a video game on that
front it's never going to be able to
outdo
a video game on the sort of
visceral nature of the action
but what a comic can do is it can
layer in text the way a novel can it can
have just sort of
you know subtleties of dialogue and
narration that are very hard to do in uh
in other media and do it alongside
a sort of
you know imaginative
um set of you know phantasmagorical
imagery in a comic we can go from from
world to world and monster to monster
all within the space of a page
when you know it would have taken
a video game or a film you know months
or years of work to create that many
environments um and so we we have sort
of a limitless budget um in a comics
world and all of that all that pairs up
very nicely with the the ambitions of
the uh assassin's creed universe
i'll quickly extend that question uh you
alex but i do have to say fantastic
oracle is probably the coolest word i
have ever heard in my entire life up
until this point and it's absolutely
something i am going to take with me and
keep in my back pocket
i do want to say it's always cool seeing
how how these stories can take new
shapes across different mediums i just
said kind of fill in the gaps within
within each other uh thank you both so
much for sharing all of your insights on
the project you can pick up assassin's
creed valhalla's forgotten miss at your
local comic book shop or online retailer
thank you thank you sebastian
and now i'd like to welcome clement
from french american podcast studio
paradiso clement was a co-writer and
producer on echoes of history ragnarok
the history documentary podcast about
north mythology which was launched a few
weeks ago in english french german
chinese and brazilian portuguese on all
streaming platforms
hi sebastian happy to be here
thank you so much for your time uh come
on are you able to share a bit about
yourself and your role in the
development of the podcast and a bit
more about the studio pretty so as well
yeah sure sure well first paradiso is a
french and american podcast studio you
said it the main team is based here in
paris but we have also a small unit in
los angeles and we produce different
types of podcast journalism
investigations documentaries
kids stories too and of course bran
contents such as the ones we produce for
ubisoft um i personally joined paradiso
uh last december to work on different
podcasts including what would become
later ragnarok
on this specific
project i was co-writer and producer
which means that during the writing
process i oversaw
the work of our writer
judy gweze and i wrote myself some parts
of the episodes especially
especially the texts of uh gylfi uh with
the character that introduces and ends
uh each episode uh and after that i
manage the the recording sessions and
the post production with my co-producer
on the project axel gobert
amazing so i guess before diving into
this project i want to quickly ask how
familiar were you with neurosmythology
as a whole and
did your experience working on this
project give you a new appreciation for
it
well i had a big advantage here because
i do am a huge fan of north mythology uh
because i'm not gonna lie marvel movies
my first contact with this mythology was
with the movie thor i was i think
16 uh when he came out in the in theater
and i just fell in love with the world
of course it helped me a lot getting
into the production of the podcast i
already had some solid bases on on the
on the topic
but i
kind of did more because i read the the
eda
which is the main source of the north
mythology it's a small book written in
the 13th century
so i read it and i had like the official
uh version back in the days
of what was most mythology so yeah
as you said in terms of like
experiencing the content through through
movies and through other kind of pop
culture as well as um through theater
the
the
actual texts how do you think that
podcasts as a content form works so well
with these types of stories
well uh simply because it relies on the
power of the voice
we are used to think that documentary
equals tv or cinema aka images
but actually 90
of the time what makes a good
documentary is not the images it's the
story you're gonna tell
if your story is strong enough then you
don't need images it's like uh like a
good book
you don't have images in a book like not
since we are kids actually uh and and
it's just the power of imagination that
does all the job and it does it even
better than a screen
so that was the starting point of our
reflection on ragnarok we wanted
something that would make the listeners
uh dive in the story in the north
mythology from the beginning to the last
minute and julie uh who wrote the text
did an amazing job for that uh she
perfectly balanced the historical
accuracy and uh a novel like narration
if you will uh
and and
from the beginning we were on a good
track i think uh i was really confident
that we would have this immersion that
we were looking for
and we pushed it further in the
recording phase
uh where we we asked the host the
different hosts from for each language
kind of to put us in a cocoon with their
voice
so we we would leave the story of these
gods through their voice
and it kind of feels like they are
telling us the story like you know
around a campfire at night and you're
just listening and you're absorbed by
the words um you're pulled into the
story
uh and the last but not least uh part of
this project was mixing and editing and
in the podcast uh world that's probably
the the most important part and
here our team did an incredible job
using the the music of the game
of donna ragnarok to uh to
put the the podcast the text in music
the words in music and also adding sound
design so sometimes you're gonna have a
wolf
uh wandering around and you're gonna
have like the the son of his
of his pose on the ground the son of his
roar uh and that's just something you
have the the son of the of thor uh
with hammer for example when he's
fighting giants all of this uh concourse
to uh to create the the ambiance the
atmosphere that we were looking for for
an audio documentary but obviously
ragnarok seems to be a concept that a
lot of people have at least a
rudimentary understanding of why do you
think that that is or or why people find
ragnarok specifically to be
interesting yeah sure again pop culture
did a
huge deal in our knowledge about this
word
most people know the world now but they
don't
necessarily know what's behind it
and
um
there are common misconceptions uh of
course people
like associated with the end of the
world which it is actually
uh and it's kind of the same concept as
the judgment day in the bible it's the
same there are
interconnections between these two uh
these two visions of the end of the
world
um
and it's really influenced by
christianity actually it's not
very nordic uh to to say um
like the flames of hell burning the
earth that's in the uh that's in the
bible that's the apocalypse and
it was written
like eight
to lay yeah that's it eight centuries
before the vikings uh conquered england
so of course
there was some influence of christianity
over the conception of ragnarok so
actually when we look into ragnarok we
look into the christian culture the
christian texts the bible
and that's something people don't
necessarily know
yeah absolutely and
hearing all the passion that you've had
for this project i think the next
logical question is can we expect more
assassin's creed related history
podcasts to come in the future
yeah sure i can't say too much now about
the contents but
we will meet your expectations
i can guarantee that uh we are already
developing new podcasts for ubisoft but
yeah there will be more assassin's creed
related podcasts with narrative stories
uh you're gonna know more about history
some facts that you didn't know uh
you're gonna maybe cross the way of some
characters historical videos you might
have seen in in the games if you are a
passionate gamer um so yeah this very
exciting content on the way so yeah stay
tuned and keep listening to the ubisoft
spot guys
i i appreciate the the expert teasing
that you
were weaving in and out for um one of
the most exciting things for me uh about
assassin's creed is this inter
inter-intersectionist interconnection
between history and mythology and pop
culture so thank you so much time so
much for your time uh come on for for
talking with us about this podcast and
uh if you'd like to listen to all five
episodes of the echoes of history uh
podcast be sure to check them out on
your favorite streaming platform
you want to know more about the norse
gods
a word of warning you will not be
disappointed
i used to be like you i only knew the
superstitions i worshiped the strength
of thor and odin and feared loki's
mischief
who am i
my good friends my name is gilfie king
of sweden
not the sweden of today no a sweden from
times long past
like you
one day i decided i wanted to know more
about these famous gods who watch us
from the sky
so i went to get them myself
i met three of them
their names high
just as high
and third
and here's what they told me
assassin's creed black flag is easily
one of my favorite assassin's creed
games so i'm incredibly excited to get
into our next topic eastern shores await
edwin kedway in the official sql webtoon
to assassin's creed black flag i'm
joined by etienne bouvier transmedia
content manager for ubisoft
hey sebastian nice to be here today
thank you so much for joining us can you
take a moment to quickly tell us a bit
about who you are and your role on the
project
of course so i think i'm no stranger for
people who watched last year live stream
as i was already talking about our
transmedia initiatives
basically i'm the one helping our
beautiful partners our beautiful artists
our beautiful writers deliver on good
content on the assassin's creed
franchise i help coordinate with the
production teams making sure that
everything is consistent
and mostly making sure that everything
is at the level of quality that we
expect on our transmedia projects
all right that's amazing thank you so we
should probably start with the obvious
question and can you speak about what a
webtoon is and where people are able to
enjoy them
of course because that's quite a new
format right
but new means exciting and that's why we
were so eager to uh explore that format
so webtoon started in korea a few years
ago it is basically an illustrated
format and very often the artistic
direction
is close somehow to manga
and so it's a digital illustrated format
that you can read by scrolling through
your phone on an app so it's really a
vertical format that was designed at
first for people to read when they
commute to their to their job you know
so it started in korea and now in it
expands worldwide you can find webtoon
content everywhere in the world you can
read it on dedicated apps and of course
that's where you will find where on
assassin's creed webtoon
that's really cool being able to take
assassin's creed anywhere on your phone
to your point earlier about edward being
a really well loved character so
obviously he's a fan favorite dude his
charisma and his wit um how do you think
the webtoon has been able to capture the
spirit of that classic character in a
new way
so edward
he's that
cocky character very funny
i think she really embodies the the free
spirit that is
you know the legacy of the assassin's
brotherhood
so it was really nice to work with such
a character because he brings lots of
color to the narrative you develop
around him
also edward he embodies adventure
discovery and with that project we
really wanted to have those
thematic pillar at the core of the story
so you see edward allows us to have a
very character driven
narrator
that conveys that sense of adventure
he's always eager also to
discover uncharted territories and since
we knew that we wanted to set that story
in a completely different area in a
completely new area southeast asia
we were convinced that edward would be
the perfect
character to support
that story
what's interesting is that the story is
set
later in his life so he's a bit older
he is
i'd say a seasoned character now and uh
it will be interesting to see how the
edward we knew in black flag evolved
into that
seasoned pirate who still has that taste
for adventure and a good fight of course
i have one final question that kind of
alludes to something you had mentioned
earlier when you were teasing
are you able to share how long the
webtoon will be like how long can we
expect to sail with edward again
so that's something i didn't explain at
the beginning but webtoon it's a
serialized
format
it really works like a tv show so you
have a weekly episode
launching every week
for a long period of time
we plan for the first season to have 40
to 50 episodes so that's roughly one
entire year of content
and that's only the first season but
we really want to have
several seasons probably free at least
so if you start reading that story you
know that you're
sailing for three years probably along
that storyline and with that character
yeah that i guess that's a lot more
robust than i was that i was expecting
that is obviously going to be
an amazing opportunity to relive this
story and to jump back in over the
course of the next
several years um so i think i speak for
a lot of assassin's creed fans when i
say thank you etienne being able to sail
with edward once again is going to be
super exciting uh so keep your eyes
peeled edward will be back in on all
webtoon platforms this summer
i'm really eager to speak with our next
guest about her experience adapting the
assassin's creed universe into novels
kate hartfield is with us today to
discuss the magus conspiracy the first
novel in a brand new original trilogy
called the engine of history these books
will be published by aconite books which
will be launched this summer in english
and shortly after in many other
languages
very happy to be here
yes thank you so much uh kate can you
share a bit about yourself and your past
work for those who may be unfamiliar i
heard you were recently uh a sunday
times best-selling writer from the
embroidered book i was yeah that was
quite a surprise yeah so uh the
embroidered book is my most recent novel
uh it's about marie antoinette and her
sister charlotte um but they're
magicians that's the twist uh so that
came out in february in the uk and
elsewhere and is just about to come out
in north america i've also written a few
other books with historical settings and
a couple of interactive interactive
fiction projects
for choice of games
so i usually do work in historical
settings and this is my first time
writing anything for assassin's creed
that's amazing so it seems like kind of
like a natural evolution like the the
next the next step in this history genre
for you so obviously as this is the
first time writing for assassin's creed
for this novel so obviously the time
period is incredibly multifaceted what
made 19th century europe the backdrop
for this particular story although i
suspect that i might know the reasoning
behind that
yeah one of the things i think that
appealed to us about this period um is
the
the rise of assassinations of political
assassinations in the 19th century so
you know queen victoria had eight
attempts on her life uh all of which she
survived uh several monarchs were not so
lucky um
so it was you know there was a lot of
political turmoil going on in this
century and a lot of assassination and
um you know
power was crumbling in a lot of ways we
had the revolutions in 1848 that swept
across europe and um even though they
didn't succeed in all of their aims
everything seemed to be changing and the
old structures were falling down so it
seemed like a natural
century to explore a little bit more uh
what was going on with with the
assassins and templars during that time
yeah absolutely and obviously the nature
of the history obviously brings into
question the historical figures of the
time i know aydah lovelace is a as a big
component of the novel how present uh
would you say she is in and
how meaningful her contributions to
mathematics play in the overall
narrative
yeah so ada lovelace we know today
mostly as um
sort of the the foremother of the modern
computer uh you know she's one of the
very central figures in in the idea of
the invention of the computer and sort
of foresaw it in a way uh with her work
with charles babbage
but she died very young she died at the
age of 36 in 1851 and
my book
covers a longer period after that so
she's not around for the entire book but
she's a presence in it and one thing
that i found really interesting about
her is because she died so young and she
had already done this
incredibly formative work and she had
all kinds of other things on the go and
all kinds of other projects just had an
amazing brain and a lot of her papers
were destroyed after she died because
she was as scandalous as her father lord
byron so
many things were kind of swept under the
rug so there was a lot of scope there to
imagine what else she might have been
working on and what else she might have
done had she lived so i explored that a
little bit in the book
to your point earlier you mentioned
them being built as very compelling
characters what do you think are the
elements that make a compelling
assassin's creed story
i i do think character is really key to
all of the assassin's creed stories um
you know there's so much scope to
explore complex personalities because
assassins are by their nature complex
that that's the entire foundation of the
creed is that you know nothing is as
simplistic as it might appear paradox is
built right in so we have the
ingredients for interesting characters
with internal conflict right there
um so i do think that every character
that we see in assassin's creed is
really the foundation of the story and
the two main characters in this book
simeon and pierret are both
um complex and have uh you know a lot
going on and a lot uh a lot of choices
to make and so i think that's uh that's
what i found interesting about their
story um the other thing that i really
love about any assassin's creed story
obviously as you can tell from my
background is that i do love history and
i love being able to work uh within
known history and ask questions about
what might have been
and um
you know in a in a novel um you can't
really recreate that incredible sense
when you play an assassin's creed game
and you're up on the rooftops and you
think i am actually in paris you know
like it's you know you can't create that
sense of immersion but you can have a
different kind of immersion
and so i tried to kind of echo that
sense of being there in prose as much as
i could
amazing um well i i want to say thank
you so much for your time in free energy
kate uh novels are able to weave such
rich narrative worlds and i'm thrilled
to be able to jump into the story you've
created um and a story that you'll be
able to pick up in your local bookstores
or online retailers very soon thanks so
much
well friends that's it for today we're
working on a bunch of amazing projects
and i hope that something you saw today
has sparked excitement for you to go in
and explore assassin's creed in a
different way i'd like to say a final
big thank you to all of our guests the
excitement and
insights you've been able to provide us
have been incredibly interesting to hear
and i also want to say a final big thank
you to all of you these projects are an
embodiment of the passion that you have
for this franchise and we will continue
to expand our worlds together while also
revisiting some iconic characters from
the franchise
so don't forget to keep your eyes out
for the anniversary celebrations taking
place for assassin's creed 15th year
anniversary thank you for joining us
we'll see you all soon
[Music]
you